obviously we don't know how dinosaurs
would respond to getting shot with a
tommy gun
i'm pretty sure that they would respond
pretty much as we see here and
not be remotely troubled by it hi
everyone i'm jonathan ferguson i'm
keeper of firearms and artillery at the
royal armouries museum
i'm going to be breaking down some clips
from video games all of which feature
the thompson submachine gun
or as we know it more fondly the tommy
gun
move out and take position hostiles
okay pause first thing i'm struck by
watching watching this is the rate of
fire question with the thompson
so the depicted as really quite high
there
but the the variant in uses is the m1
which is the
military version and one of the changes
there was to reduce the rate of fire
this sounds to me i haven't got the
ability to kind of
count it but it sounds to me more like
the model 21 model 28
which is more in the ballpark of 900
rounds per minute but it certainly
certainly sounds
like a tommy gun enemy contact
okay pausing again of course in in a
game what you need
are quick reloads reloads have to be
slick they have to be fast
famously with the thompson by modern
standards it's extremely fiddly to
change the magazine
even the the box magazine depicted here
feels a bit like a three-handed job but
though pulling off
a string of super slick reloads with
that
awkward magazine which you've got to
locate into a t-shaped slot
so there are various impediments to
these really slick reloads that we see
pulled off to the micro second of course
um i don't think i've ever seen
variation induced in reloads unless
you're doing some sort of mini game like
in as in gears of war or
oh something something else is the use
of iron sights
with the m1 version of the thompson
we've got the simplified
rear sight you've got two rear sights
there's the circular aperture and
there's
a notch in the top and what i notice
about the clip
is that we are looking at the notch in
the top
now if i remember correctly that is 250
yards
whereas the the aperture site the hole
in the back
is the hundred yard sight i.e the the
closer range site
to use the notch on the top you actually
have to elevate
the muzzle to get the front sight to sit
in the notch very long-winded way of
saying we're kind of looking through the
wrong site
for the typical fighting that we're
doing
in this game
so uh mafia you'll see i have my um
trusty model 1921 thompson with me just
as a reference tool
we do have a few liberties with the
model
of the gun in this game nothing nothing
too bad except that
if we look at the back there we've got
the uber simplified site from the m1
a1 thompson which is just a strip of
metal
bent up at the back the genuine thompson
that these guys would have had at that
time
has this much more sophisticated rear
sight
that flips up for ludicrous ranges that
you would never use a
um submachine gun at that's that's a
fairly big oversight i would say if
you're trying to depict that classic
gangster era
1921 1928 model
the other thing i've noticed immediately
is this thing
runs at at least 900 rounds per minute
but that is
um significantly faster than what we're
hearing here
this is almost a hybrid of an m1 and a
1928 and it's
it's chugging quite slowly almost more
like a
an mp40 or a stem the thompson even the
m1 is a relatively fast firing gun
what this game has nailed is the look
and feel
so it might be running a little slow but
um the way the character
is holding it almost kind of punching
themselves behind the gun
and the face forward aggressively it's
straight out of the gangster films
and i will believe that's how they were
really used as well maybe not the
prescribed way of firing it the way the
thing is recoiling
looks and feels about right for the
recoil of the 45 cartridge it will it
will vary
um depending on whether you have one of
these on the end
and in reality with enough practice you
can simply compensate for the rise and
pull down and there are plenty of videos
on youtube with
people doing that i could nitpick this
all day long
but it's nailed the gangster thompson in
most of the ways that really matter
all of the ways that really matter
[Music]
we're talking about a relatively vintage
game here and so
we've got a 3d model but it's not as
detailed as as maybe a
more modern game would be all the basic
features are there
even the shape of the receiver at the
back looks right got the right form of
rear sight on it
and they've put in some time and effort
on the gun it's a little prude in some
areas
but it's a low poly 3d model what do i
expect
the only thing that's kind of sticks out
is this and this is a trope of video
game
guns in video games is the ejection port
is on the wrong side
but that's almost certainly deliberate
because that enables you to have a nice
picturesque shower of cartridge cases
flying across your view
rather than immediately out of it
what we're seeing here are star-shaped
muzzle flashes
which you're only going to get if your
muzzle device has
slots in the side this is modelling the
cuts compensator which is on the end of
this gun here
where your hot gasses are coming out the
top
or obviously the front and you're not
going to get
a muzzle flash like that out of a
thompson gun i think of all of the
games that we've looked at this is the
slowest firing tommy gun yet
this is the 1920s version of the gun it
ought to be about twice as fast as it's
being depicted
it doesn't detract from the gameplay of
course but um yeah something that does
stick out
okay pausing so we're obviously looking
here at a game of a certain vintage
i think they've done they did a hell of
a lot with the processing power and
graphical power of the time
pretty good model actually of the the m1
thompson but what i've noticed is that
the
grip frame the lower receiver we're
actually seeing the mirror
side of that we're actually seeing this
side of the gun and of course
this side is where all the controls are
so when our player character
pushes up on the magazine release he's
pushing up on thin air
because he's pushing up on this side i
presume that the the gun was modeled
one side and just mirrored for
convenience although the upper does have
the correct
ejection port cocking handle on on the
correct side so this is this is just a
kind of a technical limitation but maybe
a shortcut
that was taken and it's really only
something that you would
you would look at if you're doing
something like this
the thing that that strikes me as a bit
weird
is the cartridge case ejection on a real
gun and on more modern
fps games cartridge cases are really
flying out the gun they're spinning
they're
they're traveling quite some distance in
allied assault here
they are kind of spilling gracefully out
of
work
[Music]
yeah i think it's probably the probably
the weakest aspect of the depiction of
the weapon
is the way cartridge cases eject it's an
aspect that was not really
nailed until later on
yeah not the most
faithful depiction of um old faithful
the
reloads of the drum magazine so we know
that it has to be cut
we then have to push up on this
and slide it out to the side it's not
super slow or anything but what you
can't do
is slide it up from underneath or
pull it off the gun from from below
that's
how the box magazines work this is the
1921 model thompson which is appropriate
for this
um this clip hunt there's a hundred
round drum as you've just seen there's a
50 round drum
and the uh what we call a box magazine
or a stick magazine if you like
is um 20 rounds so it's only short and
that comes up from underneath
whoever's modeled the gun has not had
any time playing with
a drum equipped thompson but of course
it's a you know it's a fast-paced action
experience and you've got to uh remove
and fit magazines
quickly and simply
i will say in terms of realism obviously
we don't know how dinosaurs would
respond to getting
shot with a tommy gun but um i'm pretty
sure that they would respond pretty much
as we see here
and not be remotely troubled by it
unless you shot them in the eyes or
something
[Music]
you